Miley Cyrus reveals what she learned
about marriage from her parents it's
amazing
the Malibu singer graces the cover of
Cosmopolitan September issue and inside
the mag the 24 year olds who is back
together with Liam Hemsworth reveals
what her mom and dad Billy Ray and Tish
have taught her about marriage they've
been hubby and wife since 1993 but have
seen their ups and downs Miley said
quote nothing and no one stays the same
grow evolve change with each other and
celebrate your loves journey
Miley's Dad filed for divorce from her
mom with whom he shares five children in
2010 but a year later announced they
were reconciling I dropped the divorce
and in June 2013 the country star filed
for divorce again in Nashville while
Tish filed her own divorce documents in
Los Angeles then a month later the two
got back together Miley and Liam have
also been on and off since 2009 when
they met on the set of the last song
you can really sing they got engaged in
2012 split a year later and rekindled
their romance in 2016
since then Miley's worn the ring again
oh we're so excited and in May she
opened up about their relationship to
Sirius XM show hits want people that
break up and get back together I think
that's awesome because you know it's
true but also you get time to be
yourself you get time to grow up
[Music]